you get up one morning try to start your
bike it's not running you do the typical
things like clean your car check for
everything and nothing's working then
it's time to look at the spark plug all
we need to do it first is remove this
spark plug boot that's connected to the
spark plug we need to do is just pull it
off take it out at this part be warned
if the bike has been run the spark plug
and the whole cylinder will be warm so
careful not to burn your hands then you
just take your handy dandy spark plug
tool and take it put it on the spark
plug and then turn it and it's lefty
loosey righty tighty normal this is in
pretty good condition it's kind of
there's a little bit of build up but
there isn't very much oil build up
around the spark plug it looks kind of
like a brownish color which is what you
want usually when it's darker like this
one and you see lots of oily deposits
means that the bike is running rich
meaning that there's a lot more fuel to
air in how the carburation is running so
usually what happens is this whole spark
plug gets fouled and then the electrodes
are blocked and they just they can't
fire at all put it back into the
cylinder I usually hand thread it in and
then be warned one thing with spark
plugs is there's two versions of this
boot spark plugs will come with what's
called like a nipple on the very end
that just screws on this particular one
doesn't use it so you need to remove it
from a spark plug and then put the spark
plug in put the boot back on
and that's how you change the spark plug
you